hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Bob race now this game
game mallet burger now this game came
out for the Ludum dare game jam and it
features the sadist robot in the
universe from The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy but I don't know if that's
direct correlation and I don't want to
make any assumptions here and also I I
think I need goddamnit I need I couldn't
find my goddamn booze became all but a
boob
is it gonna plug into I gotta restart
the goddamn game didn't just restart my
recording alright hi guys welcome back
to the bar ace we're gonna get started
now and the reason that I was drawn to
this one is because it was so goddamn
adorable because you can jump and then
you cha I don't know you
didn't give me anything I should have
looked at the controls shouldn't I have
okay ah god dammit suspected face
up against the glass no my little buddy
okay so when once you get going you
don't stop going and then you can oh
good god how is anyone supposed to
do that you sprint and run and jump
around and bam your way through glass
and then you also have a button that can
make you shrink and you just heard his
adorable little bot going through this
whole exercise and it's awesome I mean
there's not a lot hole there's not a
whole lot okay ha ha ha ha oh oh
god damn you're making it very difficult
for me it's randomly generated so
obviously it's gonna be a bit of a
problem but you can also oh man let me
try this again
good god alright oh sorry
there we go huh oh god man that's a
tough one okay it's fun but anyway I
don't know how long I'm gonna be trying
to play this because obviously I've
never been good at these endless runner
games and I don't know how not Unruh
Pettit if it's gonna be it just seems
like it like way off in the distance you
can see that it's just kind of randomly
generating pulling up random pieces up
from the abyss and there's no end of
this hallway or if there is an
and I definitely don't know how to get
to it but it's a cute little game and it
was just made for a game jamming and the
thing I love about these game jam games
is it often explores different subjects
in each each of the game jams themselves
have a theme so you'll have a theme and
I believe this one was shapeshifter
it was shape-shifting and it's just
really interesting to see how people put
these interesting concepts don't mind me
don't mind me don't mind me don't know
me
Oh God and he's fell down oh this is
okay anyway I'm gonna give it one more
guy I'm gonna give it one more go unless
it's a pathetic attempt and that I'm
never gonna do it again but I'm gonna
try to go for over a thousand meters
distance which is quite a hefty school
distance in my opinion I know there's
probably some expert level players of
this already but I'm merely an answer
who just tries to have fun in life so
don't judge me for anything I'm just
doing my thing concentration mode
engaged
a what why what did I deflate why did I
deflate I didn't aah
that's okay trying to get hmmm
why did I deflate why into flame so when
you go over a single obstacle oh jeez oh
jeez why like I want to do that alright
so I guess I gotta go round him because
I think there's a I think that I think
the I think the programming is like if
you pass over a single obstacle it will
force you to deflate and then so but if
I go around the outsides I think I can
kind of beat the system and make it
think that I'm not what whoo okay that
was a tricky one okay so if I go around
the outskirts Oh lalala see haha I know
how to beat you all right I'm going for
distance this time now I wish the only
thing I wish there was was there is a
distance counter while I'm going through
it because it seems like it's a little
questionable how far I get before I just
end up dying hit pick up a 2x index all
right we got this whoo I'm going for the
high score okay oh geez oh geez poor
getting faster P oh okay but anyway that
is BOTS run there's not a lot hell else
hmm cause there's not a whole lot to
this game but remember it was made in 72
hours for a 72 hour game this has a lot
of polish I mean there's probably some
bugs that I could exploit out of it but
it's surprisingly well put together for
a game jam game so you can find this
through the link in the description
below maybe you can beat my high score I
guarantee that you can beat my high
score because I'm terrible at it but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
recording Oh Oh God boy what big feet
job the better to do that with